hi my name's Adam I'm studying
mathematics and physics at a level the
cosmic background microwave radiation is
obviously convincing evidence for the
big bang theory but it's still just a
theory as the theory of evolution could
be potentially blown apart by fossils of
rabbits in the same rock strata as
dinosaurs my question is what piece of
evidence
if found could potentially bring the Big
Bang Theory to its knees okay Adam well
that one's a tough question as a person
who's not seen any evidence that
contradicts the Big Bang Theory it's
hard to imagine what that I'm evidence
might be but we used to have evidence
that seemed to contradict it we used to
have evidence that some stars were older
than universe and this is obviously a
problem now we fixed that problem by
understanding better how that we can
tell the ages of stars and we measured
better the age of the universe and to
get it to work out we had to understand
that the universe is accelerating and
therefore is older than we had thought
so because of those changes we're now
able to say it fits but it wasn't so
long ago that the evidence did not fit
so if something like that would happen
again if we would discover that the age
of stars are incorrect or that things
just don't fit the story then maybe
something strange would happen we could
imagine for instance that more detailed
measurements of the cosmic background
radiation wouldn't fit the predictions
now is that likely I don't think so but
it is certainly a theory that could be
falsified if strange and mysterious data
were discovered